Today, we are putting the saying,
"Grandma knows best"
to the test with using dating apps.
Please welcome her beautiful granddaughter Ashley
and this really awesome cool grandmother, Joy.
(audience cheers)
Hi guys.
Hi.
How's it going?
Hi ladies.
Hello.
Joy.
Yes.
You know, I was curious
What do you think about the world of dating apps?
I think it's probably better now,
makes it easier.
Much easier than when I was a youngster.
Much more convenient.
Much easier now
with the apps.
Yeah.
Ashley, I'd love to know as a modern woman
how is your experience on dating apps?
It's very here a mess.
But it's hard because you can't really judge.
I mean, you get the pictures, you see the prompts on the app
but you can't really tell who they are.
So it's like you're going in blind on that first date
rather than like going to a bar and just meeting them.
And he gets to gauge their personality.
And for me, it's all about personality
and rather than looks so.
I'm with you, Ashley, it is not the looks.
It is all about the personality.
100%. I mean, what I've been doing now is actually
doing like a little phone screen
before meeting them in person.
So it's, we'll connect on the app
and then we'll have a FaceTime sort of meet and greet.
And if we vibe through FaceTime,
then we'll kind of plan the next step.
Do you think you can tell really quickly on FaceTime?
Is it like, has it been a good editing process?
It is interesting, because they had
a really great FaceTime date
a week ago or two weeks ago.
And we met in person and the connection wasn't there.
I went on a date with someone fairly recently.
First date was like out of a movie.
It was perfection.
And then the second date, he was a total grump
and in a bad mood.
And I was like, "What?"
That's the thing.
Inconsistent on date two?
You have that.
I mean, what do you do in that situation?
I have no idea. I have no clue.
Do you cut them out?
The last time I had a date was what? 1960?
I mean, it's been a long time, so,
I wouldn't know, you're asking the wrong one.
And yet you are basically conducting Joy's.
I sure am and good luck.
I love it. I know nothing.
Now let me rule your dating life.
What do you look for in a man for Ashley.
Tall, dark, handsome?
Well, it doesn't have to be tall, dark and handsome
it just nice looking, gives a nice appearance.
Good personality.
Likes to go and do have fun.
All right.
Well, we're going to try to find Ashley a great date.
Let's see if we have any luck here.
Okay. Before we start,
we're going to kick it old school
and go like old dating game show with you.
And will you please put on this blindfold
and leave everything up to your grandmother.
Here we go.
This is wild.
Good luck to you.
Okay. So before the show, Joy happened to swipe right
on these three guys using apps like Tinder
and here they are now.
We'd love to welcome Maxwell, Brody and Matthew.
(audience cheers)
Hello gentlemen.
Okay. Can you each introduce yourselves
starting with Maxwell?
Hi, my name is Maxwell. I'm 28 years old,
originally from Cincinnati living in New York,
I work in sales at the moment.
Sales?
Yeah, I also, I have, like,
aspirations to be a writer, but you gotta pay the bills.
I like that. I understand that completely.
Do you right in your free time Maxwell?
Yeah. Yeah.
Excellent. As long as you're doing, that's like.
I write like personal blog type things
and I write screenplays.
Okay. All right.
So that's very cool.
Thank you, Maxwell.
Okay. Brody.
Hi. How are you?
Hey, Drew.
Hi Joy.
Hi Ashley.
I am 26 years old.
I live in New York city.
I am a digital account manager by day,
again to pay the bills,
but I also do private cheffing at night
which is something I'm super passionate about.
And yeah, I am really excited to be here.
That is awesome.
Thank you so much, Brody.
I really appreciate that.
Okay. And Matthew, who are you?
Can you tell us a little something about yourself?
Hi, I'm Matthew.
I live in New Jersey
born and raised, live in downtown Jersey city
and I'm a financial analyst
and as a hobby, I paint
as you can see behind me is a painting I did.
Yeah. You know, I'm just a fun, loving guy.
I love your painting by the way.
Yeah, very pretty.
Thank you.
Okay. For the first round, each guy is gonna answer
the question I have, and then they're gonna answer
the question that Joy has.
So my question to Maxwell is what is your ideal first date?
If you can be elaborate
For me, I, you know, I haven't been out a town lately
so I'm thinking multi-part,
usually I like to get my date involved in planning,
but I want to start off going to the Whim Museum
for a couple hours
and then maybe go to some rooftops in the
in the Meatpacking district and then FaceTime grandma
and see if she wants to meet us for dinner.
Oh, stop it, Maxwell.
Well, I love that.
(murmuring)
Yes.
Ah, very smart Maxwell.
Ah, okay
Very smart.
Sounds cool.
Okay. Now, Matthew
if you don't mind answering the same question
what would be an ideal first date for you?
So a first ideal first date would probably be like
grabbing coffee.
I used to be a barista as a side job during college.
So that's a big thing for me.
I definitely love to walk around the city, you know,
a big museum guy.
I love plants.
So like definitely like maybe even see a botanical garden
then end off with like a nice dinner and drinks.
Botanical garden, dinner, drinks.
Okay. That sounds good.
Okay. You guys are going to have to work for it today.
Joy is a no nonsense.
Okay.
Brody,
and she has your best interest, Ashley.
Yes I do Ashley.
Okay.
Don't forget that.
That's right.
Brody you're next.
Will you please tell us what your ideal first date would be.
Of course.
Well, with Joy's permission.
Sure.
Ashley and I would go to a nice bottomless brunch.
I love Italian food.
I love all types of food.
I think bottomless brunch.
We can have a few cocktails, have some nice meals
really get to know each other on kind of that deeper level.
And then I do love going to museums,
the MoMA, the Whitney
because I'm very into art and different cultures.
And I mean, if we're able to hit it off Ashley and I,
looking at different pieces of art
chatting about different cultures.
I think that's an A+ date.
Sounds good.
It's museums, bottomless brunch.
Yes, sounds terrific.
Okay. Great.
Joy based on these answers
which two guys do you think could move on to the next round?
May I ask?
You can ask and I'll tell you.
Matthew, Maxwell.
Okay. Matthew and Maxwell, if you don't mind
coming back after commercial and joining us.
Brody, Joy has made her decision.
I'm totally pinning this on her.
I'm like, it's all Joy.
She, she gave you the old.
No, I'm just kidding.
If it's okay,
we are going to move on without you
but we can't thank you enough for participating today
and we wish you the best out there
in the romance department.
And thank you so much for being on the show.
Thank you so much for the opportunity.
(upbeat music)